it's been an exciting couple of days and
a channel is finally monetized what's
going on guys my name is David Tommy and
welcome back to the channel today we're
talking about YouTube monetization and
how you can take your channel to the
next level we're gonna be talking about
all the criteria you need to understand
to monetize your channel how long and
does it roughly take to get monetized
how long the monetization approval
process takes how much you can actually
expect to get paid at the start and also
my advice to all you guys starting from
scratch today in 2019 so if you're
looking to get one ties and you're
watching this video now you probably
already are aware that you need four
thousand hours of watch time over the
past twelve months and a minimum of one
thousand YouTube subscribers to be
eligible to apply for monetization now
what does that really mean what does it
look like well that can mean you can get
all these things in one to two weeks or
it could take you one two years it
really depends on the content you're
bringing out but for me I have a very
detailed timeline for you guys that will
hopefully give you some guidance and
hopefully give you some insight of how
long it really takes to go from zero to
1000 so let's get a timeline going and
really try to understand and breakdown
how this really looks so on the 11th of
February 2019 I launched my first video
on YouTube it took me almost two months
to go from the 11th of February to the
18th of April to get my first 1,000
views on one video after that it took me
another month to go to the 27th of May
to get my first 100 subscribers so for
me guys it took almost three months from
February to May to get 100 subscribers a
month after that on the 23rd of June I
got my first 10,000 views on one video a
couple of weeks after that on the 12th
of August it took three hours to get to
my first 100 views on one video now
usually that would take a couple of days
so you can see how we slowly transition
and slowly progress to more and more
news
more and more subscribers and slowly and
slowly picking it up a week after that
on 18th of August we got to 50,000 views
in total and then only a couple weeks
after that on the 4th of September we
made it to 500 subscribers so at the
beginning it took me three months to go
from zero to 100 but then it took me
four months to go from 100 to 500 on the
16th of September it hits 600 subs on
the 25th of September it hits seven
hundred subs on the 1st of October hit
800 subs and on the 19th of October I
hit 1000 subscribers on the 19th of
October I applied for my monetization
and on the 23rd of October so four whole
four days later the monetization was
approved so for all of you guys looking
out there how long does it take to apply
for monetization and then be approved
well for me it took less than a week so
as you can see guys it took nine months
of hard work to get to the minimum
levels required to monetize a channel ok
so it's all well and good the channels
monetized but how much do you think
you're gonna be able to make from your
first day on monetization or your first
week being monetized well I'm not gonna
lie to you guys the first day my channel
was monetized I made a whole two dollars
and eighty for Australian cents so I
think that equates to about a dollar
ninety four Adal 95 from memory USD so
really when your channels first monetize
you don't actually make much the first
day and the catch there as well is that
this is all based on Google Adsense so
if you aren't making a minimum of $100
in your native currency then you don't
actually get to take that money for that
month so unless you're making at least
$100 Australian in my case from the 15th
to the 15th of the next month then you
kind of lose all your profit that month
so if my financials were to stay exactly
the same from day one then I wouldn't
make any money the first month my
channel was one
Tai's my channels only been monetized
for two weeks so at the moment I still
haven't theoretically made anything but
in two more weeks the channel will
actually be completely monetized and I
will receive my first paycheck but how
did I get there when I just told you I
made $2 on my first day well on the
third day of being monetized that
skyrocketed from 2 dollars and 80 cents
to seven dollars and thirty cents
Australian which is just above the five
dollar US mark and 11 days into the
whole monetization journey my channel is
averaging five dollars and fourteen
cents a day which means if you do your
math right it's about a hundred and
fifty Australian dollars a month from
monetization but if we think back to
that time line I just showed you guys
and how rapidly and how quickly things
exploded and evolved over the last nine
months from zero subscribers to 100
taking three months I believe it's going
to be a very similar journey from two
dollars a day to $10 a day potentially
or $100 a day in the next one year
journey but there are some downsides to
monetizing your channel if you're
looking for growth what I've actually
noticed over the past few weeks is that
I used to be at about an average of 350
subscribers extra every 28 days now ever
since I've monetize the channel it's
dropped to under 200 subscribers per
month what does that mean for me and
what does that mean for the channel well
it means really reviewing the analytics
and understanding if monetization is
even worth it at this stage it might not
be for $150 a month to be going and
losing all these potential subscribers
and views to really just get nothing out
of it so for me it's going to be viewing
the next couple of months understanding
what you guys want to see if it really
impacts you that short little ad at the
start or if it does anything at all if
it doesn't well then I'll continue with
the monetization if it does really
detrimental II impact the channel
well then I believe I'm gonna demonize
the channel until it gets to potentially
five to ten thousand subscribers where
the monetization might actually be worth
it so what's my advice to all you guys
out there going from zero to a thousand
subscribers and looking to get monetized
on YouTube well my first advice would be
be consistent pick an upload schedule
and stick to it I've uploaded a video
every single Monday from the first week
I started to today because I believe
that putting out a consistent schedule
kind of means your audience can engage
with you on a weekly basis it becomes
part of their routine they sit down from
breakfast on a Monday they watch your
video they go and do their day second
piece of advice is obviously stick to a
niche if you followed me from day one
you're gonna see that my channel is kind
of evolved and grown from a whole bunch
of different things because I do a lot
in my life so for me my channel actually
started as a fitness and entrepreneur
channel which basically evolved into
what you guys see today based solely on
tech I went through a whole bunch of
different phases from shooting Jim
workout videos to doing tutorials on
photography and videography to doing
product reviews to now doing tech
reviews so for me it was really looking
about the analytics and going how I'm
spending all this time making these Jim
workout videos that I don't actually
enjoy making I do love going to the gym
and working out but I don't enjoy making
those videos for no real return or
reward so for me it was really
understanding that analytics and going
well this last tech video I made that I
absolutely loved making and really
enjoyed talking to you guys about did
extremely well
so obviously that passion came through
this camera and it kind of exhilarated
through the channel so that's where it
grew for me and I think it will grow for
you to my next bit of advice is engaged
with all your audience everybody that
leaves a comment reply to them if you
can it doesn't matter if they're leaving
positive or negative feedback just try
keep the vibes on your channel
consistent and then if somebody takes a
step further contacts your on Instagram
or Twitter or whatever
rc4 a little bit of advice
or some more information on the video
you've just made well take that little
bit of time to reach out to them to talk
to them to give them what they're
actually looking for because at the end
of the day these are the people that are
watching your videos and they're the
ones that really want to get to know you
on a deeper level so for everybody that
has commented on my videos that has
reached out to me on Instagram or on
Twitter thank you so much I'm always
happy to reply to you guys I do take the
time out to make sure I get back to
almost every single person in the
comments and my last piece of advice is
be humble guys it doesn't matter if
you're still at zero subscribers or if
you've made it to ten million
subscribers really it's all about
engaging with people and being genuine
being humble and being likeable I guess
it's no really different life in general
just because you're talking to a camera
instead of a person face-to-face doesn't
mean you have to act differently doesn't
mean you have to go super hyper or super
happy and fake it for the camera just be
a hundred percent genuine be 100 percent
humble and your channel will eventually
grow and that's all I have for you guys
today thank you so much for watching as
always I'll see you next Monday